[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي
عرفنا البشري بدا يوصل لقمم متعودنا عليها
من قبل في شتى المجالات عامه وفي
التكنولوجيا خاصه في نهايه العام الماضي
وبدايه سنه هادي 2023 فوجئنا باخرها
شو راح يكون شعوركم لو قلت لكم انه هناك
اختراع جديد بيستطيع انه يقوم بمهامكم
بضغطه زر فقط
يكون فيها ولكن كمان ينهيها في ثواني
معدوده في الغالب السؤال اللي راح يدور في
ذهنكم هو عن اي نوع من المهام انا عم بحكي
شو راح يكون رايكم لو اجابتكم بانه عم
بحكي عن معظم ان لم يكن كل او اي مهمات في
مجال دراستكم او عملكم
مثلا يمكن لهذا الاختراع انه يقوم بكتابه
ورقه بحثيه عن اي موضوع كان او انه يكتب
سيرتكم ذاتيه او حتى انه يعطيكم السيل من
النكات والقصص المضحكه ان لم تعجبكم طبعا
هاي النكته تقدروا انكم تخبروا البرنامج
انه يصلحها او انه يغيرها او حتى انه يبسط
شرح المواضيع المعقده اللي بتستعصيه على
الفهم
مثلا انكم تخبروه انه يبسط هذا المفهوم
الفلاني لسن خمسه او 10 سنوات الى اخره او
انه يحل المسائل الرياضيه المعقده وانه
يشرح خطوات حلها خطوه بخطوه وبالرغم من
انعدام المشاعر عنده الا انه تخيل هو قادر
على تقديم المشهوره لكم بشان علاقاتكم
الاجتماعيه مع الاهل مع الاصدقاء مع
الحبيب وهذا مش كل شيء ولكن ايضا بامكانه
او بامكان هذا الاختراع كتابه انه
الموسيقيه تخيلوا
وبيكفه فروعها على فكره بامكانه انه يكتب
الشعر والادب وان كان طبعا اهتماماتكم
علميه اكثر من ادبيه فهو كمان قادر على
كتابه الجوردميات وبرامج الكمبيوتر
وكتابه مواضيع وترجمتها كمان لعده لغات
الحقيقه يمكن هذا الاختراع عمل اشياء كتير
كتير بس انا بصراحه تعبت من الكتابه
هذا الاختراع هو حديث للعالم كله
ومجتماعات التكنولوجيا خاصه في اخر
الشهرين تحديدا اسم الاختراع وتشات جي بي
تي هو روبوت او مجرد تسميته عربيا برجل
الي مخصص للمحادثات اطلقته
الامريكيه في نوفمبر 2022 واللي تم تحميله
مليون مره تخيلوا في اول خمس ايام بعد
اطلاقه للعلم روبوتات المحادثه مش
تكنولوجيا جديده فاول تجربه لها تمت سد
عام
1966 لكن هذا الجي بي تي اروعها واكثر
تقدما من كل النسخ السابقه بمراحل وقبل ما
ندخل في التفاصيل المتابعين الكرام بحب
ارحب بضيفنا في حلقه اليوم الاستاذ ادهم
الغامدي مؤسس مؤسسات تك بويس
حسابات على كل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الحقيقه وانا يعني عن طريق هذه الطريقه
اهتديت له من كثر همم يعني غنى المعلومات
والمحتوى اللي هو طبعا بيشاركنا فيه على
صفحات واهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ ادهم
نشكرك على استضافه الكريمه
همم حديثنا اليوم عن شات جيبوتي اللي همم
يعني همم كثر الجدل حوله كل الناس عم تحكي
عنه في مخاوف همم بتدور بشانه همم ليش كل
هالاهتمام فيه بهذه المرحله وانا طبعا
يعني همم بوقت لاحق منها الحلقه راح اشرح
للمتابعين شو بيعمل بالضبط بشكل تفصيلي
ولكن حابه اسمع منك رؤيه كلاب شو هو همم
برنامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا
الكذب هو اشتهر لانه يعني احنا لما نيجي
نشوف فعاله محركات البحث يمكن لنا 10 الى
15 سنه نفس محركات البحث ما تغيرت وثلاث
ارباع الناس يعني ما بتستعمل الا جوجل
هي عباره عن دردشه
اصطناعي بتسالوا اي سؤال بيعطيك الاجابه
فورا بعكس جوجل اللي انت بتدخل بتكتب
السؤال بيطلع لك لينك كثير وتقعد تختار
وتدور ايش الاجابه صح والافضل هو بيخسر
عليك الوقت بتسال سؤال وبيعطيك رجال مباشر
فقط قديش الناس يعني كانت تحتاج شيء بهذه
الطريقه
وبيقدر يعطيك جواب فيك كل المجالات يعني
هل كل المجالات تخضع همم يعني كيف بدنا
نقول تحويلها للذكاء الاصطناعي الاشياء
اللي احنا البشر نتميز فيها له همم اغلبها
شغلات متصله بالابداع
صعب تعلم احد الابداع
هو صعب ولكن انا يعني
صدمته في شغلات يعني مثلا عنده خلينا نقول
انه شويه مضحكه
لانه قد يكون المقالات او الشغلات هذه
نعتبرها
وبيكتب طريقه يعني ممتازه خلينا نقول
بالاضافه الى ذلك بيختصر الوقت في شغلات
اخرى مثلا صار في ناس بيقول مثلا اكتب لي
ايميل لمديري احمد انه انا اعتذر عن
الاجتماع او غير بس بتكتب هذا الجمله
البطيخه وبيكتب لك اومال او رسمي همم
بطريقه صحيحه بيرتبها لكن انت بس تعمل
تعمل اعتماد او ارسال رساله شخصيه
ممكن يكون طيب اسمح لي خلينا نتابع يعني
اخبار متابعينا الكرام حول تفاصيل هذا
البرنامج ومتابع الحديث
فكره
بنيت على تصميم جي بي تي 3 واهم ما يميزه
انه بيستخدم خصائص الذكاء الاصطناعي
والديب والمشيين لونين ومعالجه اللغات
الحيه ونماذج لغويه ضخمه لانتاج نصوص
شبيهه باحاديث البشر روعه تصميمه بتتمثل
في انه المستخدمين اعتدوا الاعتماد على
النسخ التكرارات السابقه لروبوتات
المحادثه لما ياتي الامر لكتابه مقالات او
اجراء محادثات لكن هذا الروبوت الجديد جعل
المحاولات سابقه لشركات عملاقه اطلقت
برامج
شركه متى بيجعلها بصراحه عند المقارنه فهو
قادر على تخمين كيفيه تصحيح اوامر كتابه
البرمجيات بل زي ما ذكرت سابقا ايضا اطلاق
نكات فكاهيه دمه خفيف يعني
لكنه لا يزال يعاني من مناطق قصور ادائيه
بالرغم من انه متقدم بمراحل عن اقرانه
واللي اطلق بعضها من اقل من عام فقط الا
انه بيعاني من بعض المشاكل خصوصا لما
يتعلق الموضوع بدقه ردوده وظهور بعض
علامات التحيز عند شرح او مناقشه بعض
المواضيع لكن اللي بيجعله مختلف هو انه
بعد استخدامه اتعامل معه لبعض الوقت
فاحنا اذا ما سالناه سؤال فهو لا يجيب من
نقطه الصفر بل على العكس هذا الرابط
بيتذكر محدثاتنا السابقه معه وبيربطها
ببعضها البعض وبيربطها كذلك بسؤالنا
الحالي وهذا هو الشيء اللي بيعجز عن فعله
الروبوتات السابقه له
هو فعلا اقرب ما يكون للتفاعل مع انسان
اخر ولكن يمكن في بعض الاحيان هذا تفاعل
مع هذا الروبوت ممكن يكون افضل من التفاعل
مع انسان اخر لان هذا الروبوت اذا اخطا
راح يعترف ويقر لان هو اخطا في محادثه
سابقه بينما كثير من البشر ما بيعترفوا
بمثل هذا الخطا
في صفحه المقدمه لا شركه صانعيه اوبن اي
اي تمت الاشاره الى انه اثناء الحديث التي
فانه هو قادر على الاجابه على اسئله
التاليه لموضوع تمت مناقشته سابقا زي ما
احنا البشر بنخزنها حديثنا في الذاكره
والاعتراف بالخطا واللي هو شيء قليل جدا
همم او قلم نفعله احنا البشر ولكن هذا
الروبوت بيعترف فيه زي ما ذكرت وممكن في
بعض الاحيان يرفض الاجابه عن اسئله
وبيوجدها غير مناسبه
طيب استاذ ادهم يعني كل هذه
المناحي المختلفه اللي ممكن هذا البرنامج
يسهل حياتنا في امم هل ممكن انه نعتمد
عليه بشكل كامل شو شو هي اكيد في اله
غفوات اكيد هل هو جاهز اصلا لانه ينطلق
للاستخدام ال ال العام
[موسيقى]
هو انا اعتقد انه هذا هيكون مستقبل الناس
في المحرك البحث جوجل
هتستخدم نفس التكرار الرجيم
فهذه الطريقه
بالضبط نقطه كثير
او موضوع وانا طالب ماجستير حتى ممكن اكون
ولا طالب دراسات عليا واستعين بهذا برنامج
طب انا شو تعلمت شو شو جودت هذا التعليم
اللي انا تلقيته وكيف رح يكون مضاعفات هذا
سلبا على سوء العمل وعلى المجتمع ومستوى
همم يعني جوده مش بس التعليم ولكن العمل
بعد ذلك
وكان فيها احد همم احب الدكاتره في جامعه
استراليه لان لا تحضرني اسمها صراحه لكن
كان يشتكي من هذا الموضوع وراسل رئيس شادي
شركه في المملكه اسمها اوبن ايراني
يطلب منهم ايجاد حل هذه المشكله الان
الشركه المطوره هي اوبن اي اي وعدت انها
طلعت كول او اداه ادي الاداء راح تكشف عن
هذا النص ذكاء اصطناعي ام الانسان اليوم
يوجد عده ادوات وانا بدات اجربها بالصدفه
خلال يومين فاضيه
الادوات هذه النص ونحطه بهذه الاداء وهي
بتهال مكه بالنسبه انه ممكن يكون عندها
انه ذكاء صناعي كتبها يعني هي مش دقيقه
حتى الان لكن بالتاكيد راح يطورون هذا
جهاز الكشف عن الغش يعني ممكن يكون
ممكن يكون اكيد ايه طيب هو اكيد انه
الجامعات المدارس
اثناء بحثي وجدت انه جي بي تي قادر على
تعلم مثلا كتابه ما يقرب من عشر فقرات عن
موضوع ما باسلوب احد الكتاب المعاصرين او
حتى الكتاب القدامى يعني انه قادر على
التفريق ما بين اساليب الكتابه الى اشخاص
مختلفين وكذلك هو قادر على انتاج مشهد
كامل بالشخوص لاي من المسلسلات المفضله
بالنسبه لنا اذا ما طلبنا منه هذا يعمل
هذا الشيء فلو فرضنا انه احنا بنحب
المسلسلات الكوميديه فبامكاننا انه نطلب
منه انه ينتج لنا مشهد مضحك لشخص شخصي
الرئيسيه في هذا المسلسل
وفي حال انها ما عجبتنا ببساطه ممكن نقول
له بانه المشهد غير مضحك وعندها راح يقوم
بانتاج مشهد اخر اكثر كوميديه لحتى ينال
رضانا واعجابنا
تخيلوا
ما سبق هو جزء من اوبن اي اي جي بي تي ثري
وهو تصميم لغوي هائل الحجم هذا النوع من
التصميمات بيعتمد على ضخ كميات مهوله من
المعلومات واللي اغلبها من الانترنت
وبعدين بيقوم بفرز او تصنيفها وتبويبها
هذا بيتم بالاعتماد على مبدا بيعرف
بتعزيز التعلم من خلال ردود الفعل البشري
وهو نوع من الحوار بين البشر والاله بحيث
يسال او يستفسر الشخص عن موضوع ما بقوم
البعد يعني القالب بالاستجابه والتكيف مع
قيام الشخص بمتطلبات واستفسارات اضافيه
شو ممكن تكون ايضا مخاطر اخرى طب ما انا
هيك يعني مش بس غش فيما يتعلق بالدراسه
والطلاب انا ممكن اكون كاتب مزيف انا بكتب
على تويتر باكتب
بمواقع مهمه همم انا صحفي مهم طب ما انا
ممكن هذا كله يكون مش من عمليه وليس من
نتاج ابداع الشخصي انا طب هذا شو اللي
بيمنع بانه يكون فيه كل كل شخص ممكن يكون
كاتب معنى ذلك او مؤلف موسيقي
يعني بطل في منافسه شريفه
صحيح وهو الان يعني الشركات اكيد حتبدا
تفكر في هذا الموضوع انه اوكي هم صنعه قوي
جدا بسلام بدو ينتبهوا لهذه الاخطاء وهذه
الشغلات
التاريخ يعني كل شيء بدينا في بدايته
ونستغله بطريقه خاطئه زي جوجل في البدايه
كانوا ناس يستخدم
[موسيقى]
همم تشاتشي بتي تحديدا كيف بيعمل يعني كيف
عنده هالمخزون الهائل من المعلومات
وقادر حتى انه يتعلم من هذه المعلومات
ويستنتج معلومات اخرى احنا ما ادخلناها
اصلا في هذا البرنامج لحتى يحسن نفسها هذا
اسمه
همم ولكن هو كيف كيف بيشتغل لحتى يقدر
يعطينا همم هل انتاج المتخصص في هذا العدد
الهائل من التخصصات
طبعا هو هذا بيتعلم فانت لما بتساله يعني
هي ليست مجرد محادثه بدائيه يعني مثلا انا
ممكن بساله
ايش لون السياره الفلانيه في علمك ان هي
لونها احمر مثلا انت تقدر تبني سؤال على
اجابته اللي هي الاحمر
اي سؤال ثاني فهو بكمل معاك محادثه فهي
محادثه متسلسله ليس سؤال جواب سؤال جواب
بشكل هذه المحادثه المتسلسله وهو بيتعلم
منها ايش الناس بيكتبوا له ايش الناس
بيحتاجون مع الوقت
مايكروسوفت شركه مايكروسوفت اساسا هي احد
الشركات المستثمره
جديد
اليوم او بالامس لانه بالايام الماضيه
لانه مايكروسوفت تم استثمار عشره
ليالي وكانه شركه منافسات نوعا لانه
مايكروسوفت نفسها تنتج همم يعني برامج اي
مشاهده
لا هي استثمرت فيها في ال 2018
لما شافوا تطور العظيم في 2020 تقريبا
استثمارات في اثنين مليار الان بسبب
النجاح الكبير حيث استثمر في 10 مليار
دولار فهم جزء من هذا المشروع مايكروسوفت
جزء من هذا المشروع من زمان
اللي صار انه ممكن
اللي عندهم معلومات
نقاط اختلاف عن صديقي هو انه جي بي تي
بيرفض وبقوه على فكره الاسئله الغير مرغوب
فيها اول مرفوضه اجتماعيا مثل الاسئله
العنصريه او المساعده في انشاء محتوى بحض
على الكراهيه والعنف
وبالرغم من ذلك فقد تمكن بعض المستخدمين
من الالتفاف على هذه الميزه بطرح اسئله
بصيغه افتراضيه بصراحه ليحسب للشركه
المصنعه انها كانت صادقه تماما اثناء
الحديث عن منتجها واعترفت في القصور في
امور عده منها مثلا انه برنامجها احيانا
بيكتب و بشكل مقنع اجابات الاسئله معينه
ممكن انها تبدو للوهله الاولى انها ذات
مصداقيه لكنها ممكن بالفعل تكون خاطئه
وانه برنامجها فشل في الاجابه على اسئله
في علم الرياضيات كما انه احيانا عندما
طلب منه الكتابه عن شخصيه تاريخيه كانت
بعض التواريخ خاطئه ولكن هو نوعا ما كل
هذه الاخطاء يعني ممكن احنا نوقع فيها
كبشر يعني
على كل حال في الغالب مثل هذه المشكله
كانت متوقعه وربما هاي الاختبارات على
عينه كبيره جدا هي الدافع الاكبر لهذه
الشركه من اطلاق منتجها للعامه وكل ذلك
طبعا حتى تستطيع ان اتحدث وتحل هاي
المشاكل في تحديثات قادمه
بالرغم من محاولات الشركه زرع خصائص كثيره
للحد من المشكلات المعلومات الخاطئه
والاجابات المهينه ولا اخلاقيه في
برنامجها الا انه جي بي تي مش منتج كامل
بعد
بيستخدم ادوات بسيطه ومعالجه للمحتوى او
ما يعرف
بمودريشن 2 وهاي لحمايه مستخدميها من سوق
الاستخدام الا ان البعد ممكن يستجيب
احيانا للسلوك المسيء وممكن يظهر تصرفات
متطرفات كما تقول الشركات على موقعها
الالكتروني
التطبيق معرض لانه يملا بالمعلومات
المدنيه
لدرجه انه الشركه نفسها صرحت بانه ممكن
انه يستخدم لاغراض شريره مثل انه يقوم
بانتحال شخصيه ما على الشبكه العالميه كتب
التكنولوجيا الشهير جري ماركوس قال انه
اكثر ما يخافوا هو انه يقوم اشخاص سيئين
بنشر معلومات خاطئه ومضلله على مستوى كبير
بمساعده بوت جي بي تي
فالمعلومات الخاطئه ما لها تكلفه وهذا
يعني في الغالب ممكن تكون بالفعل عاليه
جدا
واضاف مركز انه اشخاص ممكن انهم يستخدموا
هذا التطبيق لتعزيز وتحسين نتائج محركات
البحث من خلال تقييمات مزيفه لمواضيع
مضلله اما لكسب المال او اذا ما كانت
بتعمل لصالح حكومه ما بترغب بتظليل العامه
بشان موضوع معين مؤخرا موقع ستاك اوفر فلو
الشهير منع مستخدميه من المشاركه اجابات
مصدرها شات جي بي تي وسبب حسب الموقع
ببساطه لانها جابت خاطئه بالرغم من انه
شكلها صحيح لما لا يعرف الموقع هو من اشهر
المواقع الاسئله والاجوبه للمبرمجين فلوسه
امر ما على احد منهم
فهو بيذهب عاده موقع مثل هذا الموقع
وبيطرح سؤال للمشاركين اللي بيجمعهم نفس
الشغف وبينتظر اجابته
نقل هذا الوضع قال هذا مثال على مساله
وجوديه لموقع مثل ستاك اوفر فلو واكمل
ماركس وقال اذا لم يقم موقع كهذا بحل هذه
المشكله ولمصدرها هذا التطبيق فانه كمل
معلومات الخاطئه راح يكون سبب لهجر
المستخدمين له وهذا راح يسبب اغلاقه وعليه
فبالنسبه للموقع فنهي المشكله وجوديه
حرفيا
احد ابرز
الانتقادات حول تشجيبتيه هو انه حتى
باعتراف الشركه نفسها ومطوري هذا البرنامج
بانه ممكن انه يخطئ يعني يعطيك بعض
المعلومات
وكانها حقيقه واقعه وانت تصدق انها حقيقه
واقعه او بانها صحيحه وبعدين يتبين انه
خاطئه وحتى ممكن يخبرك في الشات القادم
انه همم معلش انا اخطات لما سالتني عن
الموضوع الفلاني اخر مره همم هل يمكن
تدارك هاي الاخطاء مع الوقت وهل وجوده هاي
الاخطاء بيجعله غير جاهز وغير همم يعني
يعني ان انا استطيع ان نثق فيه 100%
ونستخدمه همم بثقه
اكيد الان ما اتوقع انك نقدر نستخدم
موسيقى عميان السبب انه حتى موجوده عنده
هي ليست
محدثه الى اليوم ليست بتاريخ اليوم يعني
اخر تحديث شفته تقريبا كان في 2022 من
الذات اللي عنده البيانات اللي عنده شويه
تعتبر قديمه مقارنه اذا انت بتبحث الموضوع
يحتاج يكون محدث بشكل يومي يخليني اقول
ومش شرط انه معلومات عندكم دقيقه
يعني انا دائما يحضرني لانه تحدثنا تحدث
فيه كتير حلقات سابقه همم عن موضوعات
تكنولوجيه منها مثلا اوبتيماس الروبوت
اللي همم لهم ماسك همم انتجعه للمساعده في
الاعمال اليدويه
المشكله او يعني انا بندر للموضوع
الاعمال اليدويه فين اذا اذا فيه روبوت
يعني يشيل هم هذه الاعمال عن عاتقنا لحتى
نتفرغ لاعمال اكثر اهميه اغلبها الاعمال
الذهنيه خلينا نقول او العمل
اللي ممكن من خلاله منتج ونبدع يعني
فاذا كمان بدنا نطور برامج لتعمل هاي
الاعمال عندنا الاعمال الدهنيه والاعمال
البدنيه نشوف فائدتنا احنا وشو معنى شو
راح يكون تداعيات هذا على المستوى
الاقتصادي طب كثير ناس راح تخسر اشغالها
في كثير همم اعمال جبس ما راح تكون موجوده
وفي ذات الوقت ما في يعني وتيره استحداث
اعمال
وجوبز جديده
هو كلامك صحيح وانا شويه اتفق مع هذا
الراي بس بعيدا الخاص اذا بننظر بهذا
الموضوع
في ناس بتقول لك انت قلتيه في ناس اخرين
بتقول لك لا اوك صحيح نحن هنخسر وضرائب
ولكن
هذه المجالات ربما تخلق وظائف
جديده يمكن ما كانت موجوده
بالضبط
كده زي مثلا الناس اللي بيطير وهذه
الروبوتات والشغلات هذه
فاكسر وظائف لكن ربما نكسب وظائف اخرى مع
اني انا شخصيا بشوف انه فعلا وتيره
الوظائف الجديده ليست بنفس
الخساره الوظائف اللي كاتب
السؤال الاخر كمان طيب هو يعني
شخص ملياردير مثل لهن ماسك او همم بالجيت
او حتى الشركه همم
[موسيقى]
يعني راس مالها اكثر من ميزانيه الدول
بتقرر انه انا بدي استثمر بهذا المشروع
بدي اعمل روبوت همم من هذا الشكل او ذلك
الشكل او برنامج ذلك
وهذا الشيء ممكن انه يؤذينا على المدى
الطويل وما في اي هيئه رقبيه لها
دوليه جامعه ولا حتى محليه في كل دوله او
في كل منطقه طب يعني ما راح يكون هناك اي
رابط هؤلاء الناس بيقدروا يعملوا رميتهم
اياها يطوروا اللي بدهم اياه سواء كان عن
جد مفيد للبشريه ام لا وبدون اي ح- حسيب
بدون رقيب
هو يعني للاسف انه خلال السنوات الماضيه
ما كان في احد يحس بانه هذه ممكن تاثر
علينا الين تقريبا جوجل طول الذكاء
اصطناعي
هو مازال يختبروه داخلين داخل شركه جوجل
احد الموظفين المهندسين جوجل طلع وصلاح
اعتقد التكاردين
بكل الاحوال
في وقتها طبعا جوجل اكيد
الموضوع لكن وقتها بدات شويه نقاشات وكيف
نقدر نحتوي هذا الموضوع بالمستقبل للاسف
الى الان خلينا نقول
الموضوع مو معقول بشكل الوحيد اللي بيتكلم
عن خطر التكاثر
بينما البقيه يشوفون انه لا ما حيكون في
خطر دائما
الاختراعات اللي كل شوي بيطلعوا لنا فيها
الموضوع هيك بيحسسني وكانه همم يعني هذه
الاختراعات مش كلها في بعض منها اكيد
مفيده جدا همم ولكن كانها تزيد
المليارديريه همم كم مليار زياده وفي
المقارنه همم بتخلي اللي صاحب الملاليم
يخسر حتى ملاليم للاسف
اكيد صح صحيح
مع انه طبعا اكيد يعني ما حدا بقدر ينكر
فوائد الانترنت كل ما نقدر نعيش مع بعض من
دون الانترنت ولكن
يمكن لانه ما في اي اي رقيب واي جهه
بتراقصرحوا كثير يمكن
بالاختراعات و بتطوير الاشياء ان شاء الله
تكون دائما مفيده وليست مضره قبل ما ننهيه
همم بحب اني ارجع على سؤال اخر في ما
يتعلق بتهدد بيتي الملفت فيه كمان برده من
احد همم
الانتقادات عليه بانه يعني قادر انه يعطيك
نصيحه شخصيه في علاقاتك مع اسرتك مع شريكك
مع كذا ولا درج لانه شفت خبر بتحدث عن
امراه قررت بناء على همم جواب سؤال لالها
همم هي سالتها قررت انها تنفصل عن زوجها
يعني كمان كوارث ممكن تصير ههه
ممكن كيف ممكن يعني كمبيوتر يتعاطى بمشاعر
بصراحه بس
كنت قاعد اقول يا رب انه مو كذا القصه
يارب
شيء غريب يعني ما ادري كيف في ناس ممكن
تثبيت
ربي
ايش اسوي في حياتي
الصراحه يعني احنا اللي قاعدين نعطي
الذكاء الاصطناعي
المفروض انه بايدنا يسيطر عليها ان شاء
الله
شكرا جزيلا يعني على كل هذه المعلومات
المفيده وهذا الحوار اللطيف استاذ ادهم
الغامدي وان شاء الله اكيد رح يكون في
النا اللقاءات اخرى في كلام منطقي
شكرا جزيلا لكم وان شاء الله شكرا
في ختام حالتنا بحب اني اسال مثل ما سالت
سابقا في كثير من حلقات هذا البرنامج الى
اين سياخذنا هذا الطوفان الهائل من التقدم
التكنولوجيا والاهم هون هو انه في خدم من
الانتاج اللي يبدو وكانه لا يهدا
هل من الممكن انه يتوقف هذا القطاع
والعالم معا لبعض الوقت فقط لحتى نقوم
بجرده حساب ونتعرف على ما قد يبدو في
ظاهريا او وقتيا وما هو مؤذي على المدى
المتوسط والطويل وهل سيكون هناك جهاز او
جهه او حكومي يمكن بتقوم بتنفيذ هذه
الاختراعات المتتاليه لحتى تسقط السيء
منها وتبقي على الجيد اما انه احنا رح نضل
ننتظر لحتى تحدث المصيبه وبعدها راح
نتعامل مع المشكله
المصيبه هي انه المشكله لما تقع فانها ما
راح تضر صانعها فقط بل راح تضرنا جميعا
دون استثناء فهل يقرر العالم الضغط على زر
توقف للحظه
في اي وقت قريب
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان باذن
الله
[موسيقى]